Most productivity advice is backwards.
You've tried the 5 a.m. wakeups that
left you exhausted. The complicated
systems that took longer than the actual
work. Your mind can only juggle four
things at once. Not seven, not 10. Four.
Every time you switch tasks, you lose 23
minutes. Not seconds, minutes. You're
not multitasking.
You're rapidly failing at multiple
things. Want the secret? Work in 20
second bursts. Drop your room
temperature to 68° F. Wait 90 minutes
before your first coffee.
These aren't theories. They're tested
methods that double output while cutting
effort in half. If then planning alone
doubles your success rate. If it's 2
p.m., then start important work. No
decisions, just execution. Ready to
become dangerously productive? Watch the
full video